it's just like this tangy but savory
explosion in your mouth like what more
do you want
right hi I'm Kevin J Wynn and today
we're gonna make my family's recipe for
it that ball low block which is also
known as Vietnamese shaking beef
Vietnamese shaking beef is stir-fried
cubed beef served over a bed of greens
growing up my mom would make Vietnamese
shaking beef all the time and I just
remember the first time she made it I
was just like what is this I think
honestly I was like seven years old and
my mind was blown and in college I would
try making this and be like something's
off but my mom would honestly be like
Kevin do you want pictures and be like
yes please she would send me videos of
her cooking the dish to be like hey
Kevin you got that being Vietnamese just
brings me so much joy and for such a
long time I wasn't surrounded by a lot
of Asian people in general so the moment
that I found like community in
connection with individuals who look
like me who has shared experience as as
me I felt less alone in this world my
family honestly is a bunch of meat
eaters but vegetables are important it
is essential to the dish
we always go the extra mile to make it
look nice but for Mia just give me all
the meat that's what I want
get your walk super hot and the meat
should start browning a little bit and
you're gonna flip it you should be able
to see a nice little char on your beef
all right now is the fun part there's a
reason why we call it shaking beef it's
because you're gonna shake up your walk
and you're just gonna shake shake shake
it's a fun little activity Vietnamese
people love our dinner parties you can
have your bun sale your koi cool your
bunny me is pure deliciousness this is
exactly how my mom would make it this
tastes like home I love to ball up luck
it's simple it's easy you get meat and
rice that is the way to my heart it's so
freakin good
you know Ezreal go
oh yes
you